there was no sign of Nicholas sturgeon
at her Glasgow home on Monday the woman
who for 10 years was front and center of
Scottish politics and the campaign for
Scottish independence now avoiding the
spotlight her successor as SNP leader is
resisting pressure to force at a step
down from Parliament while the police
investigation continues I'll do what I
believe is right to the values of
natural Justice and Nicola sturgeon like
Colin BT like Peter model of course
released without charge and therefore I
think there's no reason for their
membership to be suspended Peter Murrell
is sturgeon's husband and the former
chief executive of the SNP Colin Beatty
is the party's former Treasurer all
three now questioned by police about
what exactly happened to some 830
thousand dollars in campaign funds which
has disappeared from the party's
Financial accounts in the center of
Glasgow we found sharp divisions and
strong opinions about sturgeon and the
pursuit of Scottish independence I think
that it's quite clear from recent polls
that you know the country doesn't want
to hasn't wanted it didn't want it 2014
doesn't want it now
uh and even the first ministers even
agreed with that now so you know they
should go and actually manage in the
country instead of you know trying to
get the new divisions everywhere we're
unhappy for Nicola she's she has we
don't support her but she has worked
hard I think what it needs to do is have
a refresh a branch enrich Shakedown so
that you can they can get back to what
actually matters to fundamentals I mean
people talk about let's not talk about
independence let's talk about the things
that matter the things that matter
are because we don't have Independence
if you really want more honest opinion
on it the UK's top polling analyst says
the impact of the police inquiry has
been surprisingly muted among voters
what is more of an impact is the low
ratings for Hamza Yusuf he's got
negative net satisfaction ratings even
within SMP supporters he's clearly not
necessarily regarded as competent and is
capable of Nicholas sturgeon and that
seems to have been the event and the
outcome that's resorted in the SMP now
being down to 38 the SMP remains
comfortably the largest party within the
Scottish Parliament and the impact of
these criminal proceedings won't be
tested at The Ballot Box until the next
parliamentary election in 2026 but
nonetheless the very fact of the
criminal proceedings has certainly
tarnished the party's reputation and it
faces an uphill struggle to restore
public confidence Paul Brennan Al
Jazeera Glasgow